Among The Sensational claims in Prince
Harry's new book are allegations that
Prince William physically attacked him
Harry says he grabbed me by the collar
ripping my necklace and he knocked me to
the floor I landed up on the dog bowl
which cracked under my back the pieces
cutting into me I lay there for a moment
dazed then got to my feet and told him
get out also in the book he details a
conversation he had with his mother's
friend and psychic Sally Morgan where he
asked about his mother's death he wrote
In the book that she told him quote
you're living the life she couldn't
you're living the life she wanted for
you
well Sally Morgan joins us now Katie is
still here and also we've got
psychologist honey Lancaster James down
the line
um Sally hello wow great to have you
with us
um what are your thoughts
dear Harry where do we start yeah I mean
well it's to me he is dear Harry I know
that you know he's taking an awful lot a
stick at the moment but it's his way of
grieving I think as well I think that
he's great I I you've got to remember I
know him or spoke to him because of his
grief and uh yeah that's I think that
it's all of this all of his behavior
it all traces back to how they were not
allowed and I'm including William here
yes they were not allowed to grieve in
the way that they wanted to for their
mother so I was fascinated to learn that
Harry contacted you and he appeared in
the conversation he had with you to be
troubled about whether or not his
mother's death was really an accident is
that correct well that was the first
thing he said to me what did he say uh
the first thing was hello how are you
um and remembering a
and then he said I really need to know
what you think about my mother's death
and I just said to him in me I was a bit
shocked
um and I thought well it's not my place
to give him my thoughts he's asking me
as a medium as a psychic and I said you
need to speak to your Aunt Sarah Sarah
mccorkindale that was Lady Diana's
sister that's right now I thought that
was incredibly interesting because this
is new to me so you advise Prince Harry
to speak to Princess Diana's sister
about what really happened because I
thought he shouldn't he needs to get he
needs to get the information from her
she was the one that said to me four
days after the funeral when she rang me
at home because I used to see her on a
regular basis at least three times a
week right she was
um most of the time the Princess of
Wales lady in waiting she would go on
and so she would travel down from
Norfolk I live just off the A3 at the
time she would pop into okay then pop
into me on the way back to Norfolk so
and I she rang me we were very four days
after the funeral and I was really
shocked because the first thing I said
to him when I picked up the phone yeah
um
what what are you doing ringing me you
know your grief you're grieving and she
said oh Sally I just there's a few
things I just wanted to say to you and
she wanted to talk about a tape but I
because every single reading is taped
right they took the tapes yes
um and there was a tape that she was
really interested in that they had
listened to on the train yes on the way
to autrop yes and so she spoke about
that and then she said to me what do you
think happened and I said well it was an
accident wasn't it just so just to be
clear then Princess Diana's own sister
four days after the funeral was
questioning whether or not Princess
Diana's death was truly an accident well
that's right well that's how you see I'm
telling you what she said to me we can
make of it I'm not saying you're not
right but when she said to me will you
always will you promise me that you will
always say her death was an accident and
I went well it was wasn't it and she you
know why would she say that to me let's
go to honey uh honey good evening thanks
for joining us so you've heard these
extraordinary Revelations these
bombshell claims uh from Prince Harry in
this book I mean what are your thoughts
about the State of Mind of Prince Harry
how how difficult will it be for him to
to try and seek some form of
reconciliation that he talks about given
what he's done
well the truth is I mean I wouldn't like
to comment on what his State of Mind is
at the moment he's not my client if he
was my client I have to say I wouldn't
be giving any interviews at all I've
caused that confidential
um but what I can say I mean certainly
the revelations of what has been printed
in this new book have been coming thick
and fast today I mean my phone has been
off the hook everybody is talking about
some of these allegations some of the
things that have been published and so I
think if we sort of reflect on those
claims
um I mean it's my specialist area to
support public figures that's the area
that I generally work in uh my company
on set welfare we work with production
companies around the world we specialize
in supporting people who live their
lives or work in the public eye and what
I see from people that we've worked with
over the years when they do a tell-all
book when they they go live to the world
with some big Revelation is often an
individual I mean we work very much with
the real life person we try to get
things from the horse's mouth and what I
often see is that there's usually been a
very long time before this big moment
this big Crescendo where it all comes
out where this person has privately
struggled to hold a lid on perhaps some
things that they've desperately wanted
to talk about that advisors have said
they shouldn't or people have said to
them that
um you know you should keep this all
behind class so that's the only I can
think really he will have known the
impact of these Revelations
um
how will he be feeling now it's going to
be all over the world's newspapers for
days and weeks I mean how were they as a
couple
how will they cope with this what would
be the impact on them
well one thing I'd like to think is that
they have support and one thing that
Harry and Megan have been public about
is that they do have mental health
support I think Harry has talked about
that in his book as well how he has a
therapist or therapists some people
providing them with support and I really
hope that that is robust
there is a weird discrepancy though
isn't there honey in the in the book he
talks about this extraordinary Showdown
with William and which became physical
William allegedly knocked him to the
ground and the first person uh Harry
says he called was his therapist at the
same time as having previously suggested
that Megan wasn't able to get a
therapist because that wasn't the done
thing in the royal family how are we to
reconcile these two conflicting
narratives from him
well well again it's my understanding
about Megan's comments about that was
that at a particular time she wanted to
go somewhere and get help she says that
she wasn't uh permitted to do that I
think that is different
um but what I think Harry's done there
is actually something that in some sense
psychologically was probably a sensible
thing to do if that's what he did
because at a time when your emotions are
running High it actually can be much
more helpful to turn to a professional
for support than to your close family
member because they are involved and
they will have feelings about it as well
and they'll be sort of too close to the
issue so in that sense I would say
anyone else out there anyone watching
actually who has been through major
sources of conflict in their own family
lives let's face it this is a very
common thing I would say it is helpful
as you say honey he is going to need and
Megan are going to need a lot of support
thank you so much honey indeed Sally
final thoughts I mean just on this
extraordinary day
um completely extraordinary I don't
think there there'll ever be a
reconciliation with the brothers but
it's it's never going to happen I mean
and I think that it's so sad because one
of the things that he said to me when I
had that conversation
we spoke for a long long time he wanted
to know how his brother he said my
brother how will my breath be knowing
that William was you know the the heir
to the throne this is the tragedy of it
but he's he's probably permanently
destroyed the closest relationship oh
completely the the pair of them had yeah
and I think any any form of
reconciliation will be literally for the
public eye for just how it looks I don't
think it's going to have any depth to it
I mean I very much respect to what honey
had to say there but I can't help
feeling that too much therapy has been
part of the problem I'm here you know
this is a young man who's been
encouraged to share his feelings to
explore them all and actually hasn't
known the limits of keeping that within
the confines of the consultation yeah I
mean just some of this stuff frankly I
don't think most of us want to hear
there's just so much I don't want to
know about him losing his videos all
this sort of very personal detail
Stardust off everything is there any
prospect that actually that'll that'll
in some way endear him to me yeah no I
don't want to think no one wants to
think of him as being used like a staff
we're being a bit older I mean are you
speak for yourself
zero dear dear oh dear